Nadia vous allez avoir drit à une
interview dernier coup vous êtes prête
on ne bouge pas pendant le
[Musique]
jingle Nadia dernier coup dur dernier
coup dur avec mon fils ce matin ah oui
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait bon c'est cogné
la tête il dort avec moi donc vous
dormez avec lui ouais tu quel âge quand
dorm avec ma femme d toujours avec mon
fils pour ça je me renseigne a 18
ans non mais ça va il a 2 ans là ouii
c'est un bébé et le papa il est pas il
est pas un peu vénère de pas dormir avec
maman non non il est sympa
euh bah la question se pose pas puis voà
là à mon avis c'est une gaffe c'est pas
une gaffe du tout c'est pour savoir
c'est une
ouverture ça n'a rien d'une gaffe
dernier coup de cœur à mon fils ah oui
ah oui ouais il y a rien eu de depuis le
fils il prend peut-être beaucoup de
place à la fin
ouais mais c'est faut pas vous fixer
trop sur ce bébé non
plus il m'apporte beaucoup quand même et
j'ai la chance de l'avoir parce que
c'est vraiment une force et ça ça me
procure beaucoup d'éc jeevoir des emails
moi c'est incroyable je voir ça d'email
je veux bien être le papa d'an je suis
sûr dernier coup de
point non c'était lors de du tournage de
mon clip en fait il y avait le champion
d'Europe de Kungfu et voilà on a fait
des petites Ahou d'accord c'est
professionnel dans les coups de
foudre dernier coup de
foudre dernier coup de foud c'est pas
hieratherine qui est très intéressé vous
connaissez oui très bienès très bien
dernier coup de gueule dernier coup de
gueule ah oui avec la directrice de la
crèche de mon fils ou
ouais parce que je voudrais lui dire
j'ai j'ai récupéré mon fils avec avec
une morsure à 100 et ça m'a pas plu quoi
je norm là je
l'ai par un autre élève ouais par un
autre bébé enfin un autre enfant quoi ça
arrive à ma petite sœur un truc de
morsur dans les crèches c'est
horrible il faut faire non mais quand
quand il y a peu d'enfants avec avec pas
mal de référents c'est pas normal quoi
donc là j'ai tapé mon mon petit scandale
mais tu as bien fait ah ben plutôt ouais
dernier coup de fil bah mon fils là
juste
avant dernier coup de rouge non jamais
ah jamais h vous êtes musulmane oui Ahou
vous pas le droit non c'est j'ai pas le
droit c'est sur c'est c'est que déjà
l'EUR j'aime pas j'aime pas l'odeur du
non
c'est c'est bien cette religion
musulmane d'ailleurs parce qu'on a le
droit de fumer des pétards non je sais
pas jamais essayé non plus
elle fait des DISY elle dit qu'elle
jamaisé fume pas pas me qui fume
beaucoup je l'
déjà mais d'accord mais je veux dire il
va pas fumer son c'est pas quelqu'un qui
a son paquet de cigar son joint
aveciam la D fa voir c'est
joli
dernier coup de soleil il y a longtemps
il y a longtemps dernier coup de bol un
250 m car à 3000 francs par mois non
voyez loup non je rigole c'est Tibé
n'est pas
passé la Noé non non pas de ça chez nous
he ça se fait pas avec de la Noë les
gens r plus d'appartement moi qui étais
dans le comité de soutien de la Noë ce
qui est très drôle c'est le jour où il
nous a tous réunis pour nous remercier
il a surtout ne compte absolument pas
sur moi pour obtenir quoi que ce soit ça
très très bien mon petitard dans mon
bureau mon bureau montitè qu' P pour
j'espère qu'il le pense vraiment avec la
pub que tu lui fais évidemment qu'il va
te remercier voilà Monsieur grill cro je
le crois ou oui je crois qu'il l'a dit
et qu'il ESS de faire c'est sympa c'est
mignon merde il est
nulécoute blous hier soir hier soir
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il avait rien
à la télé ah ou
la télé toute seule le soir avec Yanis
Yanis il fait dodo quand même il il est
tout
se alors question cruciale dernier coup
de rein ce matin la salle de F parce que
je fais beaucoup de sport je m'entraîne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
énormément